the only thing i think people love more
than their kid or love as
nearly as much as their kid is their dog
and um and so i'm surprised that there's
not a place like disneyland for dogs
that is basically the happiest place on
earth for dogs
[Music]
dude next thing is kind of weird let's
see if it works
yeah what's your prediction let's do it
uh let's predict it now you think this
goes anywhere you think it becomes worth
something or no
so the background here is our friend is
this guy named nick huber who goes viral
all the time for writing about like
storage units uh self self he's a self
storage guy on twitter his handle is
sweaty startup i'm an investor in his so
i'll disclose that i don't know what
that means here but i'll we'll say it um
he created he made this thread like as a
joke or he made a joke about tomatoes i
don't even remember the joke how he
could grow tomatoes and sell them or
something and people like made fun of
them and it went crazy viral
and then he created a tomato nft project
called
bromados
as a joke but kind of not a joke do i
think it's gonna go anywhere kind of
like well executed where you're like
this isn't a joke the art is amazing the
art is great
it's great in the sense that it's like
well executed bad art like it's a tomato
that's a bro that's a guy so
uh do i think it's gonna go anywhere of
course not no i don't think so
do you
there's a chance
uh like
i don't know if you saw that he uh he
posted a tweet from
this account that's called i think cosmo
davichi or something like that did you
see that tweet that he posted where
somebody
he's like oh this just got interesting
and um
that's that is one of the most popular
nft
curator accounts they own like tons of
punks and
board apes and whatever and it's
supposed to be a snoop dogg snoop dogg
is the one who uh i don't think it's him
who writes the tweets cause it's like a
totally different writing style but he
says it's snoop dogg um snoop dogg says
it's him and
they funded it obviously with like
millions of dollars worth of nft
purchases
and so i thought that was kind of
interesting that he's got some um
some you know some heavy hitters in this
uh this nft world and a few collectors
space together how did he do it so like
he told me that i think there's like
either one or two or three like there's
like four thousand i don't remember some
like single digit load
usually it's ten thousand or eight
thousand but uh it doesn't matter but
let's just say ten thousand because
that's what most of the projects are how
do you literally make an image because
like his images are all different is it
like some code where you're like
you have like 18 different features and
it's and it swaps them yeah exactly so
you have all these traits like hair
eyes nose mouth body shirt pants
whatever
and then each one might have 10
variations 12 variations 25 variations
so there might be 25 hairstyles and then
you go through and you set you so you
have an artist make 25 hairstyles and
it's just the hair part
and then they say you say the rarity you
say okay this is the most rare hairstyle
the golden mohawk
i only want that to appear one percent
of the time so you put that in all into
a program
and it spits out a collection of 10 000
variations 10 000 combinations of these
things
and with the rarity uh so that some of
them have the super rare attributes and
then some of them have very common
attributes that's how all these work
what program do you use for this
i don't know what people use i think
it's maybe just one smart contract or
maybe there's a special app for this i'm
not sure what what people use
damn i mean that's crazy that's that's
crazy to me but it's gotten so easy that
like you know
nick can take his tomato meme and get it
done now he hired a good artist because
the art he has is like actually like
really good it's 3d art it's really
really nice but you know you see a
different
um
10 000 art collection drop you know
every four hours or something in the
comments okay so like i bought one
yesterday so if you go to openc
dot io i saw this it's really it's funny
like these are such a
it's such degenerate gambling um but i
saw this thing go if you see it on
twitter early you should basically go
mint the thing or buy the thing so i saw
this thing called chain runners it took
off uh right away i saw people i saw
interesting people on twitter talking
about it i think uh
the first guy who really i i think i s
the guy who kind of think kicked out
kicked it off in the tech industry was
the founder of figma
who this guy's zoink um
and so the founder of figma which is
like a multi-billion dollar design
company
uh he is a big nft collector he he owned
one of the most rare crypto punks so he
changed his profile a picture to this or
or like you know posted about it and
immediately like i start i started
seeing every vc doing it so i bought in
and you know i made double my money in a
day and you know you can get in and out
of these things very quickly um
there's another uh i'll tell you about
another one of these this is kind of in
the weeds so i almost regret doing this
early on in the show but let's do it
there's this thing called wolf game so
go to wolf dot game and i think this is
kind of a sign of something that's to
come
it's a little confusing when you when
you first go to it i only understand
let's say
thirty percent of it right now but
the part i understood made me think oh
this is something new so what is
this
so crypto is now going into gaming and
what does that mean that means like
in the old way of gaming you would put
like let's say a game like world of
warcraft
people who played world of warcraft
would spend thousands of hours grinding
that game playing that game leveling up
their characters earning new stuff
and they would get zero economic value
for it so you would you would put you
know thousands of hours in and you would
get zero dollars in return but hey you
got the shiny helmet and your character
now says level 60 congratulations it was
that was still good enough people did
that people all around the world do that
then games like fortnite come out
fortnite says hey you can play this game
it's about shooting each other but
you can have your character have all
these special eye special um costumes
they do nothing for you in the game
they're all it doesn't make your
character any better but if you buy our
in-game currency called v-bucks you can
buy these special like capes and swords
and helmets for your character all right
great people spent billions of dollars
on v-bucks
um and and bought tons of stuff in the
game
and if they decide like many people who
were 12 years old playing fortnite and
dropped you know 180 in the game buying
stuff
now if they're tired of fortnight they
want to go play a new game
that that money is lost you cannot take
your items to another game so why is
crypto gaming going to be big it's going
to be big because
when you buy an item in a game you're
going to own that item and then other
games will allow you to bring that item
in so it'll make it'll make it way more
valuable to buy things in games because
you're gonna be able to use them you're
gonna be able to resell them later if
you get tired of the game and somebody
you want to sell it that doesn't exist
today in most games and secondly you'll
be able to take it with you to other
games all right so now let me tell you
what this wolf game thing is
what a wolf game is is it's almost like
a gambling system so you imagine uh if
you go to the website it's like little
pixelated art
like 8-bit yeah it looks neat like it
looks like kind of punk rock a little
like
i all this this whole this whole genre
of people online it totally is like the
freakers what was it called you know
what i'm talking about like the um
uh like the steampunk type of vibe yeah
yeah that's definitely like this big
overlap of like steampunk and crypto so
here's how the game works
in a very
again i don't even understand the full
game but here's how it worked when i
when i went to it
you could buy a sheep so let's say you
buy a sheep
if you if you stake the sheep in the in
the barn meaning you put your sheep in
the barn every day you're going to get
every sheep produces 10 000 uh wool
and um and so your sheep is kind of like
working for you it's like farming wool
for you okay and wool has some value
well wall is like it's the in-game
currency it's like v-bucks so so you buy
a sheep the sheep produces wool for you
okay that's interesting
you could also buy a wolf
if you buy a wolf or you own a wolf
here's how a wolf works
this is the story of the game the story
of the game is if you put your sheep in
the farm
they're safe because the farmers have
made a truce with the wolves to say do
not attack
uh the sheep in the in the farm
and in exchange for the safety it's like
a mafia in exchange for the safety you
get 20 of the wool as a wolf
as
a bribe as the pace is so crazy if
somebody ever takes their sheep out of
the farm they can keep 100 of the wool
for themselves but there's a random
chance that the wolf will come eat your
sheep and take all of the wool and maybe
take your sheep or something like that
and so the wolf would then get 100
there's a small chance that you might
lose your freaking sheep
and so you could play it safe and pay
the tax or you can risk it for a bigger
reward and you can lose your sheep and
so the whole game is basically about
owning these sheep owning these wolves
and the like random chance the random
probabilities of certain things
happening and the whole time you're
accumulating wool which has some
has some value in the game right it's
the it's the in-game currency and i
thought this is very interesting it's
kind of a stupid silly game but it's
interesting because
um
it's a game that didn't just like add
crypto at the end it kind of started
with this like the game is designed
around
by this character the character earns
you money
by this other character that character
steals money or collects attacks and
it's basically a game that's made to
make you money and i don't know if you
know what's going on with axi infinity
but this is like a
yeah i mean the the the
the infinity thing is like the biggest
money maker in the world right now it
seems yeah they've made like i don't
know over 2 billion
the game has made over two billion
dollars in like a year and it's this new
model called play to earn and play to
earn basically just means normally when
you played a game you played just for
you know shits and giggles but now
if you play and you do well in the game
you actually are earning the in-game
currency which is like could be cashed
out at any time and so there are people
we have a friend that has a team of
people in the philippines just playing
the game full-time he pays them a salary
and they pay the game for him and they
it's like a investment property they
make back 25 percent
yield on top of the salaries that he
pays them he pays to play this game all
day
do
i i think i can i i i can imagine it
because um you know people will
obviously see this so it's like kind of
up uh i think a lot of people
will have a bad reaction to that so i
don't want to say their name because oh
my god i didn't ask them in advance all
right that's amazing do you want to um
all right well so like right now i'm
looking at a sheet and you've got one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten things here honestly they all seem
pretty good do you sort of like start
banging through some stuff yeah let's do
it uh your boy went to disneyland last
week had a ton of time i had to skip one
episode of the pod but that made me
get exposed to a bunch of new ideas and
then i got sick so i haven't been able
to work i've just been sitting there you
know doped up on benadryl so i got all
kinds of of crazy ideas that i want to
bounce off you the first one is about
disneyland okay so
i got this text from sean saying i'm at
disneyland or no maybe there's a tweet
it was a tweet i saw a tweet you go i'm
at disneyland and all i want to do is
land on dilf of disneyland dad i wanna
dad i wanna f of disneyland yeah have
you ever seen this instagram account
dools of disneyland no but
i understand
it's basically just like hot dads that
they take pictures of that are like
happen to be in disneyland that day and
they're always like doing something
that's hot to the mom like
oh he's you know wiping the daughter's
mouth because you know he didn't just
leave it dirty you know he's picking
he's changing a diaper or whatever it's
like that's what's hot uh that's awesome
so that was my goal i did not make it on
a different then pretty upset about it
yeah you know i will recover
um
okay so disneyland is kind of amazing
and when i was there i was pretty blown
away and my wife was blown away so my
wife doesn't really care about business
you know she's interested in it but
she's not like a nut about it like you
or me
even she like
basically grabbed my arm halfway through
the thing it was like
this is amazing she was like i'm kind of
blown away by this guy's
entrepreneurship to create this place
because disneyland is
kind of a one-of-a-kind type of idea
and it's meant to be you know the
happiest place on earth and it really is
for a lot of people when you're there uh
you can really see um
how happy people are and in doing
research for this i went and watched
this documentary about the starting of
disneyland and in the comments or at the
end of the video he goes
that's what that's backstory of
disneyland but it means something
different to everybody in the comments
say what it means to you and the youtube
comments are like
eulogies it's like essays
about what disneyland means to these
people it has like a huge emotional
register all right so let me break
make out some of the numbers so let's
start with the numbers and then the
backstory some of the numbers so
disneyland does about 3.8 billion
dollars a year of revenue every day
about 50 000 people come to the park so
you know just roughly speaking they make
about
just over 200 per guest
per guest per year
and that's that's not counting the
hotels the flights and the
and a bunch of the auxiliary stuff so a
ticket into the park is like 120 bucks
and then you spend like another hundred
bucks on food and merch while you're
there man i feel like it was a hundred
dollars when i was a kid
yeah actually it started so i went back
i was like what was the initial price of
this because disneyland prices have been
inflating actually like crazy there's a
chart showing
inflation of disneyland and it's like
just up and to the right disneyland
started at three dollars and 25 cents to
get in back when it when it launched in
1955 so you know the minimum wage back
then was 75 cents and i think the
average person's income was like four
grand or something like that so you know
everything has gone up um but now you
know they basically have a off-peak peak
time so if you go to peak time it's
gonna be 200 something bucks
normal is like 150 bucks and low is like
100 or something like that
so um
so what what happened so walt disney
basically
his story is kind of amazing so he he
grows up
and he
he's actually from your your hometown i
don't know if you know this you probably
probably do but he's from missouri
and i didn't know that
apparently there's a place in missouri
called electric park have you ever heard
of this
no because this is the inspiration for
disneyland when he's eight years old he
goes to this place called electric park
and electric park was kind of known for
two things one it was it was an
amusement park
and the second is it was really clean
and that's like one of the biggest
things about disneyland is disneyland is
really clean so imagine having 50 000
guests over to your house but somehow
everything stays really really clean um
and that was like he's fanatical about
this when he designed the park electric
park in kansas city yeah i see it
when he um
when he designed the park he made it so
that i think every 30 feet there's a
trash can because he watched guests at
amusement parks and he would see that if
you if the trash can was further than 30
feet away or whatever they would just be
like ah they would just leave it
on the ground or throw it on the ground
or whatever just dispose of it in a bad
way but if there was a can within 30
feet they would like make the effort to
go toss it and so he made it so that at
any point and i tested this out when i
was there i was i would often like check
okay am i 30 feet within a trash can and
sure enough like it's actually like
legit there's always a trash can near
you and this place is super clean so he
goes to electric park
and he wants to be a cartoonist
he uh ends up working at an ad agency
and then he creates his first business
it's called laphograms and he's
basically doing these like kind of like
animated uh cards but you know a bad
business deal leads it starts working
but then he cuts a bad business deal
where
uh he's owed a bunch of money by one
client and then they don't pay him and
the business goes under and so he says
okay
let's go to hollywood and um
and he tells his brother let's go to
hollywood and let's create another
business and so they go and they create
disney brothers cartoon studio and this
is where they create mickey mouse this
is where they create snow white that's
the first big hit so the company goes
from like in debt or making no money to
making millions of dollars off of snow
white that was like the big win
and so he's like okay
this is kind of working
and the business is doing all right it's
not going gangbusters um but it's a
float and he's working on his next story
he's working on pinocchio he's working
on a couple other stories
and
he's always had this crazy idea about
amusement parks ever since electric park
and he takes his daughter to the local
merry-go-round and he's like ah this is
like so boring like why isn't there
something more grand than just this
merry-go-round like my daughter loves
this but like this is so boring for the
parents
and this is just one ride like what if i
made a place that was um
you know what if i made a place that was
fun for both the parents and the kids to
go to
which is like a similar theme with all
pixar movies and disney disney movies
which is like the movie is enjoyable toy
story is enjoyable to an adult and a kid
it has like two layers to it both can
enjoy a different piece of it
and so he's like
and so what how did they actually come
about this how did they actually like
figure out the idea so they started by
doing research they went to every theme
park they could find
they went to the world's fair they went
to a whole bunch of places getting
inspiration and ideas and mesh and
thinking about what is bad about this
experience what can be made better so
things being dirty blah blah blah
and he's like okay um he starts thinking
about the design of the place and
electric park had this um train that
went around the whole park and so if you
go to disneyland that's still the thing
there's right when you enter there's a
train and the train will take you around
the whole circumference of the park
and he's like all right i'm gonna build
i used to tell people one of these days
i'm gonna build an amusement park and it
is gonna be clean
and he takes two guys off of pinocchio
and he says hey
listen
um i want you guys to start uh
start working on like secret project x
and um he's like you know it's a shame
that when people come to hollywood
there's nothing to see here like people
all around the world have heard of
hollywood they come here there's the
sign where it says hollywood and the
letters on the hill but there's nowhere
to see hollywood hollywood
i'm i'm so out of it is disneyland in
l.a it's in l.a yeah oh it's in
anaheim okay i for some reason i thought
it was in
florida that's disney world
got it dude you're like not in disney
you're not in the busy world at all okay
um so he i mean i know a little bit but
come on disney world at disneyland
that's an easy confuse no no that's
that's fair that's fair um so he
disneyland came first so he basically is
like uh guys if anybody came to even see
our animation studio they just see a
bunch of dudes hunched over over
drawings it's not they're not very
impressive let's build something amazing
in hollywood and the guys get super
excited they start doing research but
then
reality hits they have to they're
working on pinocchio they have to ship
it they're working on fantasia they got
to ship it then world war ii happens so
all of the all of world war ii happens
and then he comes back because he hires
this guy kimball to work in his studio
and kimball's like this junior kind of
animator guy
and
kimball invites all the co-workers over
to his house for like a barbecue or a
birthday party or something like that
and in the back in the backyard of his
house he's like oh by the way you guys
don't know this but my hobby is i build
these little trains almost like the
steamboat style train like it's like a
life-size thing it was very small uh
it's like you know one one uh
like whatever one link of a train
basically have you have you this guy's
name is ward kimball if you google him
he looks like a cartoon
and you can see his his train too so
walt goes to this thing he's blown away
he's seeing the train
up close and he's like dude ward built
this thing
okay
the whole mickey he says he comes back
to the office he sends a memo he says
mickey mouse park is back on and he
tells the shareholders shareholders say
don't do it movie studio is already on
on edge this sounds like a big
distraction it's against the charter of
the company
we don't want you doing this he says
okay um no problem i understand
i'll create a new company
so he just creates another company to
create the park he's like i'm still
gonna do this but if you don't want in
i'll do this myself
and
and he calls it like a
red law or whatever something like that
which is like you know uh
walter backwards uh is kind of the name
where he names it he starts working on
it and so he's like all right how do i
fund this thing he thinks it's gonna
take five million dollars to build
disneyland
and in actuality it ends up taking 17
million dollars to do it and so he's
like all right how do i fund this he uh
he takes his uh his life insurance
policy and he takes a big loan against
that that gives him like you know 100
grand or so to go do this
then he sells a house that he had in
palm springs so that's like the next
seed money that he goes through that
pretty quickly
then he goes all right i need some
bigger money how do i get millions of
dollars for this okay he goes to abc the
tv network and he says hey abc
you're struggling right now you don't
have much tv programming i will create
this this program called like whatever
like the wonderful world of disney or
something like that i'll create a tv
show for you that'll air every sunday if
you invest in my park idea so disney
basically puts down half a million
dollars plus another about six and a
half of loans and bonds and they own 34
of disneyland and so that's how he got
the next seven million bucks and then he
did the same thing with two other
companies and then he sold some
sponsorships he he like
accumulates together the 17 million
dollars hustled his way he hustled his
way to doing it
the other thing that he did was he was
like all right
um
you know this this thing works because
um he's like i gotta hi i gotta have
like the uh the rides work automatically
and so he created this thing where if
you go to disneyland now you sit in a
ride and you go and it's sort of like a
it's like a stage play that plays out
but it's all synchronized when your
little like roller coaster cart enters
this room the lights go on the character
makes a sound and then when you leave
the room it all folds back into its
thing and that's called animatronics and
so basically audio animatronics was like
the thing he wanted to do which was like
he wanted live animals but it's too much
work so instead of live animals he
created these robotic animals and he
said i'm going to synchronize the
movements to music on a loop and there's
this one guy who was just working on
only this
and he was kind of in front of a green
screen trying to make this like puppet
do this thing synchronized to music and
eventually they finally figured it out
and that was like the big breakthrough
so okay let me fast forward a little bit
they open the park they build the whole
thing in less than one year
they open the park and he only invited
like 1500 people to it or something like
that like invite only launch
but somebody counterfeited the tickets
and so double the number of people
showed up with counterfeit tickets on
day one because double the number of
people showed up uh everything breaks
the plumbing breaks because there's too
many people using water in the park more
than the load was able to handle so he
the they come to him their wall we got a
problem the plumbing is broken you have
to make a choice toilets or water
fountains he's like toilets for sure and
so he uh there's no water there's no
drinking water that day the asphalt was
still so freshly poured that like
women's high heels was getting stuck in
the cement
because it was like caving in it was
basically a giant disaster and he does
some pr he basically says look
um
we have you know we had to work out the
kinks give me a month and basically they
give me they'll give me some time and
this thing will be smooth and sure
enough within a month
the the baby is
you know humming and in seven weeks he
does a million visitors so it was kind
of an immediate hit once he did it
because it was such a famous idea it was
disney right off the bat
or at this air at this point how famous
were they they were like i mean they
were a big deal they weren't like
semi-famous they hadn't had like i mean
nowhere near what they are now but like
they were semi-famous really the abc
show
which he was doing while he was building
the park
was almost like the hype video for the
for the park launch was he just grinding
the whole time yeah a crazy amount of
work and so he he creates this thing and
you know it's basically the sixth or
seventh most visited tourist destination
in the world now
and um you know it's kind of this crazy
place i think
which is kind of shocking
i think disney or the theme park
division prior to covid was the most
profitable
part of the company wasn't it except for
well not profitable because they had a
lot of expenses but in terms of gross
profit yes because they had a lot of
revenue and a lot of expenses
but now disney plus is like the bigger
thing because disney plus is like pure
profit business basically took all that
ip that people loved and created a
streaming service but before that before
covid before plus i like disneyland it
wasn't
it wasn't a project it was a like a
major a value creation a lot of value
was created there i wanted to know is
this uh is this a loss leader or is this
a um
a cash cow and it's it's more like a
cash out it's hard to tell because every
company's like accounting makes
everything look like it's like losing
money you know what i mean like
accounting can make something look
amazing or terrible
regardless of it but you know the parks
division parks and resorts was doing you
know
billions like 30 billion dollars a year
or something crazy like that so it was
you know obviously became a smash
success when he wanted to do disney
world in florida he creates five stealth
companies because he's like disney was a
hit he's like i'm looking for the second
location if anybody finds out where i'm
looking the price will go up so he
creates five shell companies he starts
buying up land in florida sure enough it
leaks out the day after it leaks the
price per i think acre went from like a
hundred and eighty dollars an acre to
eighteen thousand dollars an acre
he couldn't buy anymore once the news
leaked and uh and you know he had this
like kind of like inspiring vision so
he's like disneyland i want this to be
the happiest place on earth and he's
like i want people to have no problem no
problems with their hair i want this to
be an escape from your problems you know
you know um in real life and disney
world he's like he created this thing
called epcot which uh i don't know if
you've ever heard of epcot but epcot is
basically
a standalone government agency
no it does sound like it though
epcot is like right next to disney world
it's this huge dome looking thing and it
stands for it's an experimental what is
it it's experimental prototype community
of the future
uh something like that of tomorrow and
that's what it stands for um and so what
he did was epcot is basically like
it takes the cutting edge of what the
future looks like and it creates like a
mini simulation of the future so you can
go and see the latest what the what the
future is going to look like in terms of
technology
i've been once when i was a kid yeah
it's kind of amazing and so um and he's
like you know
but all of these projects he i'll read
you some of the quotes that i thought
was pretty great for him as like an
entrepreneur he goes
um
i want this to be the happiest place on
earth i want compared to kids have fun
together
he goes um
when it came to epcot he's saying uh
where is it
he goes i want this to be a living
blueprint of tomorrow i want this to be
an always evolving thing epcot is never
going to finish because tomorrow will
always be different than today uh
disneyland itself will never be
completed it will go it will go on as
long as there is imagination left in the
world and so since then you know they
built the park for 17 million but
obviously they pour in
like hundreds of millions of dollars
every year to upgrading the parks and
changing the the rides and the themes
and all that stuff
um in order to kind of
continuously evolving so that's kind of
amazing
i originally i
i brought up six flags to you a while
ago do you remember when i brought that
up yeah
so the guy who invented
i don't know if he invented but he he
inspired me and he kind of invented the
genre a little bit of email newsletters
it's this guy named bob pittman
and he had this accelerator called the
pilot group and basically he funded a
bunch of entrepreneurs and he taught him
like he's like here's what i think you
should do
and
uh like five or six relatively big name
companies came out of it like purewow
daily candy
thrillist which is a multi-billion
dollar media company called group nine
and like two or three others that you
someone here would recognize i forget
what they're called and he did this
newsletter thing and he like made it
huge prior to that he was the ceo of six
flags oh really yeah which is kind of
interesting and before that he invented
or he was like on the founding team for
mtv he helped he was the first ceo and
president of mtv
and his uh
big thing was being prior to starting
the newsletter businesses he was the ceo
of
century 21 real estate which is a
multi-billion dollar thing clear channel
outdoor
uh he was the ceo for a minute of aol
and then he was the ceo of six flags
it was a killer company when he ran it
and i think pre-pandemic they they
raised uh they had too much debt but it
was making good money so these companies
i think are pretty badass actually and
they're going to roar back right now if
you started working on this two years
ago you'd be in an awesome position
right
um and so i wanted to talk about some of
the like kind of spin-off ideas that's
you know that's that's the backstory of
disney but when i'm there i'm thinking
how could this be better and uh so i
have one one tip for disney disneyland
itself which is
obviously the absolute worst part the
only part that takes away your happiness
at disneyland is waiting in lines so the
average ride you know you're waiting 30
minutes to 45 minutes just to ride this
ride for 90 seconds
and uh especially if you're waiting with
like a little kid the kids don't
understand that you're waiting they're
like i want to go now i want it my turn
like my daughter just it's my turn now
it's blushy's turn now let's go and i
was like well
they do kind of nothing to make the line
experience better well don't they have a
fast pass that everyone buys they used
to and they got rid of it because
a bunch of reasons i think a everyone
was buying it so it became less useful
that b
um they got a bunch of for it like
oh you know kind of elitist it's elitist
exactly so they had to kind of back off
that
so they do have this thing called the
vip tour that you can pay for that
basically takes you to the front of line
of everything but you have to pay
it's what is it it's basically you pay
six to ten grand a day for a group of up
to ten people
um and so if you're willing to drop you
know a thousand dollars per person
uh you can do you probably just feel
like a huge douche though like doing
that totally totally uh yeah because
you're just looking at a bunch of sweaty
crying babies yeah like get out of the
way plebes yeah exactly
and so uh but i gotta you know probably
just feel good so
i think the thing that they that
disneyland needs the site so there's
psychology that's associated with this
there was this um ted talk that got
popular back in the day and i don't
really remember it exactly i'm kind of
gonna butcher it but
this guy was like there was this problem
which was like with a subway station or
train station and everybody was so
annoyed uh with like i guess like uh how
long the train took to get from one
place to another they people hated
writing the driving train so they they
commissioned this like bounty they said
requests for proposals um you know
guests are not happy because the trains
are running too slowly
and
most people the common way to solve this
was engineers are like we have to do all
these we have to do this massive
engineering overhaul to make the train
go 20 faster 30 faster it's just require
billions of dollars and the transactions
shut down for two years while we rebuild
the train with this new infrastructure
that's going to be faster
and then one guy was like a psychologist
and he was like
why don't we just wait make the ride
more pleasant so that you don't feel
the the slowness of time he's like you
don't have any food carts on the train
like there should be a food trolley
that's walking through the train
for pretty cheap like stacks and he's
like the person will see the trolley
then they'll the focus will go away from
just waiting for the train to arrive to
at their destination to like waiting for
the trolley to get to them and then
they'll buy i believe and they'll be
eating the snack and like that was
uh like two a two dollar solution
that would that actually like improve
the writer experience by like you know
whatever someone amazing about percent i
think it's rory sutherland who created
this that's roy sutherland i if i
remember correctly
yeah that's right all right i knew i
recognized this guy he was so he's a
marketing agency guy and he was the boss
of ogilvy uh one of the big uh
advertising firms and their whole shtick
is just like perception and i think the
the talk is all on perception
and and this exists everywhere so like
instagram i remember when they first
came out one of the things that was a
magical experience about instagram was
aside from the photo filters was that
when you would take a photo and you'd
say post it would like instantly load
and post
and people were like how did you do this
like that's incredible and um
you know
back then iphones were so bad and the
connections were so poor that it would
take like multiple minutes to upload a
single photo onto the internet and these
guys are doing it in a few seconds
they weren't probably actually uploading
it well there's no no they weren't they
actually were so first he was like dude
why don't we just like say it's done and
then it'll happen in the background and
like whatever but people would go check
and they say oh it's not posted here
this app doesn't work so what they did
was they realized
oh every what everybody does is they
wait till the caption's done
to start uploading they may tell you the
photo the filter the caption until they
start uploading the photo what they did
was they separated and they would do it
all on one screen so what instagram did
was they would let you take the photo
and filter it and then they would say
next next you would hit a button and
then you'd start to write your caption
and they knew people take like two
minutes to write their caption like
they're trying to think of what to say
and during that two minutes they would
just upload the image in the background
so the image was already uploaded back
then like during that wait time um and
so they instead of making you wait they
did it while you were already doing
something else and that was like a big
thing so this perception stuff actually
does have an impact on products that's
what i think disneyland needs to do i
think
another example of that is when uber
first came out and maybe they still have
this when you pull up your phone or when
you used to pull up your phone they
would show you all of the cars in your
area crawling around the map oh yeah
they're so close to you and i think that
was faked actually and it was fake it
wasn't real yeah and it wasn't real but
it would make you feel like they're
everywhere and if you just click it now
it's about to be here and sometimes i
don't remember why if it was random you
would open it up and there'd be no cars
around you're like oh f that i'm gonna
go to lyft but it was fake and this idea
there's this great book called the
design of everyday things by don norman
and it's a famous famous book and in one
of the principles of great design is you
need a feedback loop for example if you
were to click a button on your computer
like a submit button and it wouldn't
tell you it was submitted or something
like that or when you close a door you
don't hear a click that lack of that
lack of feedback it it it's annoying
it's disturbing it bothers you and so
this is kind of in line a little bit
with that
yeah totally um and so i think what
disneyland needs to do is they need line
entertainment they need something to
happen in the line to keep you occupied
they need to extend the ride essentially
into the line there needs to be things
built into the line little characters
that come out things that drop from the
ceiling
you know
little magical snowflakes that fly out
every two minutes uh you know candy that
gets thrown into the crowd whatever
something needs to happen in the line
that's my my one tip for disneyland okay
besides that
i was thinking why aren't there more of
these so disney was built in 1955
and
you have six flags you have like kind of
like smaller adventure parks
but what are the other opportunities
here so i think if you take the elements
of it
you have
a target which is let's say a kids
you have ip that they love so you know
they're excited to go see mickey mouse
and lion king and aladdin and buzz
lightyear from toy story and all these
characters that they've seen in the
movies they get to see them in real life
that's the big thing
and um and then you have rides and you
have food and you have also you have
parades and
amusement like entertainment that way
so what other niches are like do you
think that there's other business
opportunities that somebody who is
like a walt disney somebody who is a
creative creative mind could go build
today what do you think is out there
yeah i i think there's many and i think
that we've actually talked about a few
so the
the first one which people laughed at
but it's kind of amazing was the museum
of ice cream
and i i thought that was amazing another
one is meow wolf meow wolf is this
business that has locations in arizona
new mexico and vegas i think i don't
remember where else supposedly they do
north of 100 million in sales and it's
basically like in it's like if circus
soleil was a museum and you could walk
around and like touch different art and
it's kind of like all in your face and
it's kind of interesting i think you can
do that um
i think that there's one thing that i
think is kind of amazing that's out
right now which is it's called the van
gogh experience and so i like van gogh
stuff my wife is like a huge into that
and so we pay money and we go to the van
gogh experience and so i i do think that
there's like little niche things uh that
you can do um related to this um i think
that like what i would do
is i would look at what the most popular
exhibits of science museums and art
museums are and i would make something
special out of it for example do you
remember like 15 years ago the body uh
what was it called um
bodies
bodies i think that's all it was that
was it was like a huge hit success
and you'd go to all the science centers
or whatever they're called science
museums throughout the country and they
have
like real life bodies that you can that
like cadavers that were donated and they
dissected them and they tell you how the
inside of the potty works that i mean i
don't know if that's a main stay
somewhere but like that's a good example
what i would do is i would look at all
the science museum and all the art
museum exhibits that are long the
longest lasting as well as all the uh
broadway stuff that's the longest
lasting and i'd be like all right well
those are all hits like why are they
hits right right things that i p that
people love yeah i think if you i think
i think that the trick here is
unbundling so i don't think you want to
make the full theme park i think you
want to unbundle components and either
just remix those or just do only that
thing so i'll give you some of the ideas
that i had
uh
while i was waiting in line for 45
minutes for a ride i came up with all
these are the ideas i came up with while
i was sitting in line so the first one
was target market um the only thing i
think people love more than their love
as
nearly as much as their kid is their dog
and um and so i'm surprised that there's
not a place like disneyland for dogs
that is basically the happiest place on
earth for dogs
i would take my dog there if i could
just have give my dog like an amazing
day
um i would do it uh you know i don't
know about you you're a dog guy too i
don't know if you have that that pull
ideally it'd be local not like you know
got to fly to l.a to go do this so maybe
it's maybe it's more like a traveling
circus but why is there not
just an incredible set of experiences
that uh dogs love you know dogs have a
blast in and you can just see your dog
doing it and take pictures of them and
give them give them what they deserve
what do you think dude it sounds like an
insurance nightmare
any more than an amusement park with
like yes on roller coasters yes
so much worse you have a foo-foo dog
that is like won't hurt anyone i've got
like a 80-pound pit bull who's
well-behaved but if he ever wanted to
hurt something he'd kill it and it
sounds like it'd be so challenging to
like i mean i would be stressed out
about that constantly
okay fair enough we got some liability
concerns all right what else
uh we've talked before that ip how do
you get great ip so disney obviously
used the disney portfolio of ip mickey
mouse goofy donald duck whatever
what are the one of the new forms of ip
so i think
if you ever use youtube for kids you're
like coco melon blippi these are
characters that they watch
just as you know just as much as like
you know
disney movies because
um so they're on youtube they're
invented by like kind of individual
people there and then they got all
rolled up by this thing called moonbug
and moonbug owns a bunch of this stuff
and then moonbug got rolled up by that
thing that kevin mayer is doing
billions i think he was the former ceo
of disney
then he partnered with blackstone and
blackstone gave him two billion dollars
or something like that to go buy all
this ip so he bought reese witherspoon's
movie studio for 800 million he bought
coke melon he bought
blippi he bought about
about all these different you know
different uh forms of ip
so i think that youtube channels have
iep that people care about that is uh if
you if you combine them all together and
there was
you know the way that disney does it's
like there's different areas of the park
for each world each character theme i
think you could do it that way
dude
yeah i'm on board with this keep going
religion is another one so um
isn't isn't there doesn't that exist
isn't there like a like a muslim version
of this
never heard of it i thought that there
was but uh in the south
uh they have their maybe it's christian
there's like a christian theme park
have you not heard of this
it's like a bible i think it's like a
bible theme park
there is uh it's in the
yes it's like a christian
i i don't the holy land experience is
one of them and then there's a holy land
and then there's ark encounter with like
a real-life size noah's ark but there is
this thing called a holy land experience
it's based out of orlando florida
yeah okay i don't know if that does well
or not but i could see
a religious themed theme park doing well
right then the merry-go-round that's
mary you know you got g you got jesus
jesus's uh you know jumping right
whatever you know you you just go
totally totally uh fun with religion
yeah
okay so it's a non-profit so you could
actually go and look at all their
expenses and revenue it looks like it
brings in
uh
10 million a year in ticket sales
yeah i think it could do i think you
could do a lot better than that them
setting it up as a non-profit tells me
that you know their ambition is probably
not not not huge there with it so i
think you could do that with any
different religion
um okay what else the other side of it
is like you unbundle parts of the
experience so maybe the parade is
amazing
and like you know the parade is is one
of the experiences that you could just
offer individually or maybe like museum
of ice cream i think that's a good
example is
it takes the
go take cute photos in front of all
these different backdrops and with you
in some costume
i think it unbundled that and it just
offered that there's no roller coasters
it's just a photo part and so i think
there's a whole bunch of things here and
i think this is going to get bigger
because
as the world gets increasingly digital
there's going to be this demand for real
world experiences but the real world
experiences can't be
something that i could do digitally just
as well it has to be unique and it has
to be sort of exhilarating in a way that
is a it's a reason to get out of the
home it's a reason to get away from a
screen and so things like we've talked
about in fitness like tough mudder or
spartan race things that are like you
know photo things like a museum of ice
cream
and now i think that theme parks are
another one where there's a big
opportunity to do this well so i used to
work for that tv show i've talked about
a bunch american pickers and we had this
store
and it was in nashville it was a really
small store maybe
4 000 square feet or less it wasn't very
big at all and people complain all the
time
like oh i thought it was going to be
huge it was tiny and people would come
from all over the world australia europe
all over the south i mean people from
the south love this crap and they would
come and they would it was free to come
and they would just want to look at all
the items that they'd seen on tv and i
remember correctly on and this was in
2010-ish
when a good day we would sell 30k in
t-shirts and mugs just at that store we
would crush it just off that store if i
was a mr beast or someone who wanted to
partner with mr beast or there's a bunch
of these youtubers they do a lot of
interesting things there's this one guy
i think his name is petcock i forget his
exact name he's this older guy on
youtube with 20 or 15 million
subscribers and he shoots every gun so
like any type of gun you can imagine he
has like shot it like an old
revolutionary gun or some like weird
experimental shotgun and it's got a huge
following but he's in the middle of like
he owns like a plot of land where it's
like it's like you know you could do
anything you want same with there's a
couple other guys there's another
youtuber named roman who's got uh he's
based out of ohio he's got this massive
plot of land and he's always like
inventing all these weird go-karts and
or mr beast always does this weird
like epic stuff if i was a youtuber i
think you could create like these epic
experiences do you remember that thing
called do you remember woodward
no what is that so woodward was this it
started out i think in pennsylvania and
it was called woodward camp and it was a
sleep away summer camp in woodward pa
and it was a huge outdoor skate park
with bunk beds and stuff and as a kid
you would pay two or three i don't
remember thousands of dollars it was
expensive enough that like my parents
never would have done it and it's in
this rural area and they uh you pay all
this money to go to this like sleep away
camp and you skateboard and bmx and do
all this like crazy as a kid that
you like think that like that you see on
rocket power or whatever and it crushed
and it eventually was sold to powder uh
or what is it called powder it's like
the largest um or vail resorts one of
those it's like the largest private
equity land owning and resort companies
in the world and they eventually bought
it for a lot of money and so anyway i
think i think there is a lot of movement
here
you saying the mr beast thing just
reminded me um have you did i talk about
this movie this documentary boys state
on here did i talk about this
no
have you have you watched this thing
no boys boys state
unbelievable documentary gotta watch it
it's uh it's on um
if it's on hulu or apple tv plus or
something like that
i got right you got recommended to me i
watched it i loved it so what boys state
is it's a camp it's a one-week camp i
think in texas
and it's austin it simulates texas
politics so you get there
and uh it's like on day one you get
divided into like kind of their version
of the democrats and republicans it's
like you know you join team blue or team
rent and immediately they become like
super tribal and like hate the
other side which is hilarious because
they just like it's arbitrary it's
completely arbitrary
so what this documentary is is it
follows
one session of boys state uh hold on one
second
if you and you could i'm actually
looking at the notable alumni from uh
it's like everyone uh like so i mean
there's like hundreds of famous people
who went famous politicians who went to
it yeah exactly so you go there and you
you get divided up so you're on the blue
or the red team democrats republicans
they call it something else i forget and
then um the documentary follows what
happens that week which is you uh you
run the party basically nominates people
so you can say i want to be governor i
want to be treasury i want to be you
know vice governor or whatever the
whatever the offices are so like there's
a handful of roles
you first um
you first you know debate or you
nominate yourself and then you give a
speech debate in your party to be the
nominee for governor and then you run
against uh the other the other side
and uh
and so it's it's kind of an amazing
documentary because it just shows how
instantaneously these games these
politics games just completely infect
your brain and change the way you act
and like these kids who are like i don't
know how old they are they seem like
they're in like 8th grade or so
i could be wrong on that but they're
like they're acting just like a
politician acts they're like making
promises they're talking about what's
wrong in the country and one side loves
guns the other side hates guns and it's
literally such a simulation and then at
the end then it follows the election and
the election happens and it kind of
culminates and like you know it follows
these five characters and it culminates
in one of them winning the thing
and um
it's just a crazy documentary so i think
that that experience of a camp is kind
of interesting too to me uh i think this
has been going on for like 70 years and
like you said a whole bunch of like
famous politicians went and actually did
this when they were kids
and um
you said mr beast that reminded me of
like why isn't there a creator camp like
okay why we talked about boy scouts
going under and like who's gonna replace
boy scouts
if mr beast basically said come to this
one week sleepaway camp and create
become a creator like create your
channel
and like it's all about you're gonna be
here we hand you a little selfie stick
with a camera and you're going to create
your vlog content you're going to create
your channel you're going to create your
brand you're going to have your fans
you're going to follow each other's
channels and like it's just a place to
like come to learn how to be a creator
and that's actually a fantastic idea
because if you look at the stats i think
that either you or me or one of us
shared something where they asked like
15 year olds what they want to do when
they grow up and like 20 or 30 like a
shocking large number said they wanted
to be a youtube creator and the second
largest thing i think was a twitch
creator like it was still the same thing
yeah basically it's a video like a
youtuber basically is number one and
that that's just kind of
all-encompassing of like an online
content creator and it used to be back
in the day like athlete musician
um you know politician scientist
astronaut and like
10 about 10 years ago you know it
flipped and uh and youtuber became
number one and people you look at that
they shake their fists and say this is
what's wrong with the country and uh
other people say other people who
realize that you can't pass a judgment
like that it's a sort of like is what if
that's what people want that's what
people want you just also if kids if
kids are actually going to follow
through on what they would say when they
were younger there would be a whole lot
more marine biologists in the world
[Music]
exactly like i would be a dinosaur right
now yeah it doesn't seem like there's
exactly that many vets out there exactly
um so i think that's a great idea as
like you know if a couple of youtubers
got together i think they have you know
and i think it's fan service too so i
think you would just become more famous
you'd build fan love and you'd print
like i don't know 20 million dollars
every summer um
running your camp uh it's pain in the
ass but you could do that and i think
like i went to a space camp from nasa
when i was like in fifth grade did you
really the state of texas sent every
fifth grader to it so it's kind of
amazing what yeah and they only did it
once so i was just lucky to be in that
timing i wanted to do that when i was a
kid so badly it's an amazing thing you
go there and you get to be in a rocket
ship and like you get to play commander
and like do all this stuff but i feel
like for many jobs there's a version of
that like i think people are fascinated
with prisons i think they're fascinating
with the police i think they're
fascinated with the army and like if you
could create like amusement parks or
simulations of that where you get to
take your pictures you get to touch the
stuff you get to see how it works you
get to learn some things uh people will
pay for that and i think they're going
to see more out of home experiences like
that get built can we
move on to the shitty billy of the week
yeah or do you want a different one
no it's good it's just a crazy story i
don't even know what the point of this
point of this one let's go to different
one
all right let's do a quick one
quick idea this i saw this i kind of
caught my eye this guy um what's his
name i'll give him credit real quick
somebody somebody sent this to us in the
facebook group
and uh i thought which one interesting
so it's a special names.cn
so
uh what's the guy's name the guy's name
mike mike benitez share this so
specialname.cn what is it basically
there's a story that came out of this
girl
who paid her way through college she's
basically made a few hundred thousand
dollars and all she does is she names
chinese babies with american names so
so basically in china
every uh chinese person typically will
have a western name so you know if their
name is hard to say they kind of know
that for for business purposes and
travel purposes it's just easier to have
to like be like yes i also go by mike or
i go buy emerald or i go by you know
samantha
and so um but the problem is you know
it's not your native thing so if it's
like if i try to pick a chinese name
right now i might pick something that's
really weird or off like it doesn't
sound quite right and so you see these
things where chinese people name their
baby like rolex uh would be like their
western name it's like no no you
shouldn't have picked that one like you
know that's kind of a strange name if
you were trying to have like an easy
western name you actually like backfired
so what this woman's service is she
you can go to specialname.cn and the
site is hilarious if you go to the
website it's like
are you on the website it's it's like
yeah i'm looking at it look at the
encounter it says the baby we named and
it says a million they've named over a
billion babies but the english is is off
yeah well the actual site's in chinese i
think it's a google translate that
you're looking at yeah
you just say boy or girl i think you
submit some information or a picture of
the baby and she just closes her eyes
basically and says
jasmine
no so you you pick five attributes like
um nice honest kind eager keen and i did
that and it gave me the names zachary
caleb or harvey and it says the famous
harveys are harvey firestone
harvey ball and then caleb caleb carr i
don't know who that is that a famous
actor
uh zachary taylor i guess the american
president yeah it's pretty funny
and so this uh site i thought what what
an example of niches make riches and
like just solve a simple problem for
people
and uh you know this girl's made you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars
just off this website and uh i thought
that was like how does it make money
just to add really cool side hustle for
a college kid
it just makes they just make money
through ads i think yeah i don't know
exactly i thought you pay her to do it
uh but maybe you're saying you just got
a name right away i just got a name i
was doing it on my phone so it might be
ads or it might be a premium upsell and
they and they and the logo is just this
generic looking white lady
like that's like the spokesperson if
that's her or not
[Laughter]
that's definitely not her
so let me do this oh yeah i know it's
like a cartoon um
this is awesome so this is a hilarious
little side hustle that i loved um
okay let's do uh let's do this shitty
billy of the week i read the story and i
was blown away this is not really
this is interesting only in that it's a
train wreck did you see this story about
this venture capitalist that came out
just now so there's this guy named
michael gogan he used to be a partner at
sequoia right like the one of the
biggest venture firms ever is he the one
who stole money from them
no he got fired because his girlfriend
came out and accused him like sued him
for or accused him of
of like sexual abuse she said you know
he's i've been in a relationship with
him for eight years or ten years or
something like that and he's extremely
abusive sexually to me and blah blah
blah
she's a stripper that he met somewhere
and then she became his girlfriend and
then whatever and this the suit he he
didn't lose the suit he you know she
kind of like he got acquitted or
whatever um
but you know still sequoia was like you
know we decided it's best to part ways
so a story came out in the daily mail
you know it's good because it's on the
daily mail which is like you know just
the the trash of the trash but it's the
junk food you can't resist
and um
basically there was some wild about
this guy so here's the allegations that
are in the article the article says
michael gogan uh he basically after he
left sequoia he goes to montana and he
basically sets up his like estate in
montana he owns like i don't know uh 100
000 square feet of like space
of houses in in in montana
he is like the big fish there he owns a
bar under the bar he created this thing
called the boom room and the boom room
is where he takes like you know girls
that he meets and he so this guy's on
his fourth wife
the article talks about this spreadsheet
of five thousand women that he slept
with and it's just
wait say that again say the five
thousand thing again
a spreadsheet of five thousand women
that he slept with is okay circle says
do the math if you so if you
if this has happened over a 20-year
period yeah
365 days times 20 is 7 300 divided by 5
that means he had to have sex with a
different woman every once in a while
every
yeah every day and a half is that crazy
what i don't believe that that doesn't
make sense to me
i don't know if it's true i don't know
if he did it or he didn't sort of like
the wilt chamberlain did this once where
he claimed he slept with ten thousand
women and people were like that means
you slept with two women a day like this
doesn't make any sense
um yeah his response by the way he was
like yeah sometimes it was three though
exactly most pimp response ever so this
guy this guy's wild so so he basically
um
there's tons of so what happened was he
had created this like security company
to cover his tracks and it's like a
private security company and he hired
these like ex-military people to run it
for him and they were kind of like his
fixers they're the ones who came out and
exposed this whole thing and are now
suing him for 800 million dollars so
they're suing him because he basically
made them do a bunch of stuff that like
got them in trouble so he'd have to pay
off women that he would sleep with um
and they would have he'd be like you
need to do this like i'll put money into
your account you pay her off
and um and eventually one guy so he had
a friend
who um the story is he he brings his
daughters over to the friend's house
um with their babysitter but then he
leaves at the babysitter has sex with a
babysitter and the friend is like dude
what the hell are you doing you just
have sex with the babysitter in my house
like
uh this is messed up and he's like
he calls him a pedophile and he's like
dude uh like
i don't you know don't don't bring up my
my flaws and like you know there's a
one-time thing and blah blah blah and
the guy's like oh this messed up and
he's like starts threatening the guy he
threatens the guy and says if you come
out and say this i'm gonna like ruin you
and um the guy's like you know if that
he then sleeps with the guy's wife as
like you know part of this part of this
process the guy gets really pissed
and he's like threatens to basically
expose him for all the stuff that he's
doing um while he's meanwhile like an
investor and all this stuff you know
leading this professional life the guy's
worth five billion dollars by the way so
he's he's a he's a multi-billionaire
himself so
the guy goes to his like security guy
and says we need to kill him we have
this guy's getting too he's too big of a
risk he threatens to bring everything
down we got to kill him and don't and
they're basically like in the article
it's like
don't like communicate anywhere except
for wicker this like self-deleting text
messaging app um and the guy goes to him
and says hey hey he talks off the ledge
no let's not kill this guy whatever but
that was like one of the allegations and
and so people have come out against this
guy but he bribes the police and so like
multiple police chiefs have like lost
their job because they failed to
investigate this guy
because he basically bought them off and
how much do you think how much you think
you'd have to bribe a montana cop to
shut up like a million dollars i mean
yeah i think i think nine out of 10
police officers would take a million to
shut up oh in my deep experience bribing
cops
i mean i have no idea yeah i think like
half a million dollars would do right
like for a lot of these women it's like
jewelry uh like he slept with one woman
then she got the husband found out got
divorced and then he paid for he bought
her a five bedroom home and also paid
for her side of the divorce
and uh you know that was like
one of the things that he did and so he
just had this like elaborate web
of
you know
crazy like this crazy sexual life
layered on to crazy like payoffs and
bribes and cover-ups
and then like a whole company dedicated
to like this private security company
whatever that means and then like police
bribery like this is
like a crazy ass three-part movie
and then you look at this guy and he's
just like this you know cookie cutter
white vc looking guy it was like such a
wild story i thought
and um
yeah sometimes truth is stranger than
fiction so i am i've read i i i read a
little bit about
like odd billionaires and i've maybe
interacted with one or two before
and does it
do have you ever met
someone who's like in the hundreds of
millions or billions of dollars who has
like some weird where like like
they have a uh
like for example this is like public
knowledge peter thiel basically employed
this this
three lawyers big shot lawyers and their
and
basically when he was outed as gay by
gawker he employed and this is a great
book by ryan holiday i forget what it's
called but he employed these three
lawyers and i forget when he was outed
but something like oh nine and he goes
uh
however long it takes your full-time job
decade yeah yeah he goes just wait for
gawker and those guys to screw up and
when they slip up tell me and we're
gonna pounce and he employed these guys
the whole time
and there's some crazy stuff about peter
thiel like for example
in the book they said that he has a
black mercedes with the engine on
everywhere he goes in the world so like
that's what like he always he's got a
team and they they have to have a car
like at all times and he also has land
in new zealand because he's a little bit
nervous about apocalypse and so my
question is have you do you think you've
ever met like a billionaire or someone
like that who's got some of these weird
ass things like a like a security force
who does
exotic things like this a fixer yeah
i think so so i worked with this guy
i've talked about him before i worked
with this crazy kind of like the
filipino guy
yeah in indonesia um
crazy guy in indonesia that was
i talked about before i mean he's like a
drop out in grade school self-made i
think he's worth 500 million dollars
kind of like at his peak and 500 million
in indonesia is like you know 10 billion
dollars here in america
and um
and you know he he had a crazy elaborate
like business like his him as my boss
was really weird like he was a really
insane boss i told you but he had a
giant projector in the office
on the wall that had everybody's
computer tracked and your productivity
was like this like he bought the
software from boeing and basically used
it to like show like your little square
would flash red if you weren't being
productive enough and i don't even know
how it was like measuring that like just
how much you were typing i guess i don't
know and it was like this intimidation
thing you know he had four women that
just managed his email um like if he did
good in a meeting he would walk in the
next day and just hand you keys to like
a new mercedes that's outside he's like
this is yours drive it around and like
you know he did crazy like that
like
i remember a meeting once where a friend
of his came in from singapore and they
were basically just openly talking about
like a insider trading slash pump and
dump scheme that they were doing and i
was like whoa that's like crazy illegal
um and they were like yeah that's great
we're going to make so much money this
is it's going to work it's going to be
you said that you said this is illegal i
didn't say i'm just sitting there in the
room being like in my head i think this
i'm 20 years i think i was 21 years old
i didn't know about at that
point but i knew enough to be like i
think this is wrong what they're talking
about and then he would you know every
day would after work would take
everybody to the bar or whoever his kind
of like insider crew was and two girls
would be there and those are like you
know his escorts for the day or whatever
and like this is the way he did business
and he he bribed officials and he did
all kinds of stuff he ended up in jail
he ended up dying in jail he actually
died this year and um you know this was
a pretty crazy life uh and i worked with
this guy for only like three months and
then i left and i came back and started
a startup here but like
you know that guy was wild like he lived
a wild life
that's awesome yeah i've uh i don't know
if i've have any first handout knowledge
of or if i've like been friends with
people maybe i have and they just
haven't told me but uh
i do believe that like people like this
guy this gogan guy
i don't know i've been practicing this
gogan guy is like on some jeffrey
epstein right like this is a modern
day jeffrey epstein situation
um maybe i guess it's not underage girls
i guess that's that's the difference but
like
basically you know just like a harem of
women and cover-ups and bribes and
intimidation and he's got this bunker
and he's like bribing police and like if
these things are true which you don't
know if they're true or not but this
thing came out it's pretty crazy uh it's
it's a wild story
yeah this is crazy i i didn't know about
this i i would believe
just based off what i believe this is
very this could be very true
like this doesn't shock me like knowing
what i know a little bit like and i have
heard like rumors of people who i'm like
secondhand or third hand connected with
that they're freaks and uh like i hear
some stories about what they do to cover
it up and i 100 believe this
and
from silicon valley who are very
successful like
things that i didn't realize until i
kind of got closer to i'm not inside
that circle because i'm not like in that
that tier
but
i had a couple friends in that circle
and it's like two things that are way
more common than i ever would have
thought swinging swinging is like super
common in silicon valley dude the
swinger lifestyle weird
it's weird you know what this pineapple
thing by the way
tell me so i i learned this from tic toc
i don't know if this is real or not but
basically like this this the silent
symbol for
signaling to others if you're a swinger
or not apparently is a upside down
pineapple so if you go to a house
and they have a picture of a pineapple
that's upside down it's a wink to
anybody else who's in the lifestyle that
hey we're down
uh i had no idea that's crazy or if
they're wearing like pineapple earrings
or something at a party
i've got a girlfriend who does it and
she uh
and and she tells me about it and my
wife and i were like
i was like sarah like
you know like i'm not interested in this
just so you know like i don't want to do
this this is this
uh and she's like yeah me neither but
it's so fun to hear about yeah exactly
i'm like uber uber dude i've got a
couple friends that are into it down
here in austin where i live uh these
guys have this company you know on it um
aubry marcus and then he's got this
other guy named kyle uh who is a friend
or works there i'm not sure the
relationship but they like they mix work
and play and they're open about their
how their they have open relationships
and they talk about it uh kyle kingsbury
i think his name is and they talk about
it on the podcast on their podcast that
they they share they share relationships
yeah it's i mean you know more power to
you if it's your thing uh i what i'm
saying is i didn't know how common that
was or like swinging or that lifestyle
but it is very common amongst like
successful silicon valley people same
thing with drugs like you know either
micro dosing or
normal dosing
of certain drugs like i guess like
there's a certain level of uh
party that i just never did and had
never had the urge to do um that i think
is like pretty common amongst uh amongst
like this group of people and like you
know good for them
dude i've i'm i'm such a prude i've been
out with like some like really powerful
people who i looked up to and i saw them
whenever i've seen him do coke i'm like
oh i i don't uh
i don't really like you as much as i
used to like you exactly
it just like it made me uncomfortable i
didn't feel i didn't like it but uh this
is crazy
and it is
way more common than i than i thought
living in silicon valley i think what it
is is like if you're a nerd and you're
now worth a billion dollars or hundreds
of millions which is basically the same
thing and you could do anything you want
you want you want to do stuff and
also if you are young and you have money
you have to up the ante consistently so
dan blizzarian has this new book out and
either in the book or an interview about
the book he was saying how he's like man
i've had every woman that i could ever
want i have private fancy chefs i drive
the best cars i fly private i do i do
the fanciest stuff
none of it makes me happy anymore
because i have to go bigger and bigger
and bigger in order to
help my dopamine and make it work and
and and now like none of it makes me
happy so i just like i try to be simple
now although like it's really hard i i
but all the items they don't they don't
bring me joy
um speaking of making me happy there was
this thing that i saw that i thought was
pretty cool it's not really like a
business idea necessarily but
i think it's worth a read so let me put
a link to it uh worship the link
um one sec let me grab it
basically there's this guy i want to
give him credit because it's a very
interesting read
um and i'll explain it while i'm looking
for the link so basically there's this
guy who dan liu i think is his name
um how do you spell it dan normal and
then
and uh go to this link so go just search
uh
or nevermind i'll just slack it to you
um
so go to this link and
this guy this post and basically what
all he did was he's like hey um
you know there's there's all these like
claims that you'll hear commonly you'll
hear them over and over and over again
and they've referencing studies
and um they have fancy names and then
their reference studies that people take
them as facts and then if you're he's
like turns out if you actually go read
the study
the claim is either way weaker than what
people use it as like i think or it's
literally the opposite it gives four
examples and i loved reading this so i
want to go through them real quick so
one is unhappiness which you just said
so we had talked about this before which
is people have this thing where they say
there's a
there's a link between happiness and uh
and income and basically the thing
you'll hear in pop science is
seventy five thousand dollars you know
your happiness doesn't go up beyond that
amount so what does this mean and it's
totally small you should chase money and
um
don't chase money you should it's not
gonna make you any happier
and so he's like so he goes and he's
like because it's become common
knowledge that that money doesn't make
people happy how much is enough um you
know people have different things if you
google it if you say happiness income
it'll say um household income of 75 000
after that your day-to-day happiness
doesn't rise
um he goes
this happiness uh income
like study was actually done multiple
times not just one time
and um
and you know the problem is like when
people looked at the graph it looks like
happiness goes up up up up up and then
it flattens out he's like the problem is
it's on a log scale and like most people
just don't know how to read a long scale
graph a long skill graph means you're
going up by factor of 10 every time
sorry so even if it's even if it's
flattening out that might be
going from 10 to 50 it just doesn't look
like as big of a jump because it's not
like the increments are a log scale so
basically if you actually look at it
if you actually look at the and you know
this got published in dan gilbert's like
book uh on on behavioral you know
economics and stuff like that
and basically
um
if you actually look at the chart the
chart shows that
uh if you look at it on a non-log scale
which he puts the graph here it's
basically like the more money you have
the more your satisfaction goes up and
there's no flattening out
it doesn't go up at the same rate so yes
it's true that going from zero dollars
to thirty thousand dollars to seventy
five thousand dollars gives you a bigger
jump in happiness than going from one
million to two million or two million to
four million
but the happiness does keep going up uh
your life your satisfaction does keep
going up on all the reported scales it's
basically like you know there may be
some point where
you stop getting returns but we haven't
found it yet
you know like uh on average people have
not found that yet so
um
actually there are things that like
um that i and if you dig in he actually
pointed out some that there's there are
some things that
that uh contradict this claim so what
people used to say is oh yeah you'll get
that money then you'll return to what
they call your set point of happiness so
you get all this money you win the
lottery
yeah within a few months you're back to
your set point of happiness if you're
depressed before you'll be depressed
after
and um and he's like you know
it turns out that that's not true
winning the lottery actually does make
you happier if you look at if you
actually look at the study
the second thing is the the reverse they
also say is true something bad happens
to you people will say oh you're so
resilient you'll bounce right back to
your previous level happiness and he's
like actually if you look at the study
it actually does show that disability
divorce loss of a partner or
unemployment actually have long-term
negative effects on happiness
and even like unemployment after you get
re-employed it still persists and that's
what the studies actually show he's like
it's kind of amazing you know
how this can happen like
the study literally says what the answer
is and that people will summarize it as
something completely different like
they'll either take a very weak effect
and make it sound like it's a total like
strong effect or they'll take something
that said no correlation they'll say
it's a correlation he has four examples
or usually what happens is like there'll
be a time where um
someone has one cute line in a study and
then a news article cites it
and then
a thousand things exactly here's another
example of that
yes have you heard that uh it it's a
crazy stat i don't remember exactly
somewhere like half of americans can't
afford a 500 bill if an emergency came
up so i
i went and read i was like i don't
believe that that's true and i went and
looked at where i started i researched
this a while ago and it's it's
it's that that's a
what happened is um
there was a study done and there was a
line in the abstract saying like uh you
know like this could be as bad as
it said something like a non-committal
like perhaps
or maybe or like something like that
where it's like i forget exactly how the
scientists or the the the
how she phrased it but it's it's not
true it's not a fact it was like a it
was just a line and so many people cited
that and ran with it to believe it's
true another example is uh i believe the
food pyramid so the food pyramid i if i
remember correctly they were it was like
a hypothesis or something it was like we
just we think this might be true
um and like some people were just kind
of tink it was like a it was like a
project someone was tinkering with and i
think it was who the world health
organization took it and ran with it and
they're like well you know we don't know
if this is real and in fact in the 90s
they had to change it because they're
like well we actually put like all fats
and all carbs in the same category when
they're like
you know it was just like this
oversimplification that some people were
just tinkering with and someone ran with
it and there's loads of examples we
should actually do an entire podcast
just on examples of that
another one is like dude have you ever
heard that you could see the great wall
of china from space i've heard that is
that not true
it's of course it's not true if you can
see the great wall of china from space
why couldn't you see like a highway
yeah it's true the height wouldn't
really matter
because it's so easy to get these
one-liners and run with them and you can
they're really cool you could find a lot
of them in interesting studies and i've
actually been learning peter atia this
guy named peter tia has this really good
blog post on how to read studies and so
i read health studies all the time and
you can go and read them and they'll
make these broad claims but you'll say
oh well you tested this on only 20
people
and they just these 20 people like
called you or checked in with you
occasionally for the like three weeks
like they called you every other day we
don't know what they were doing
throughout the day like there's just so
much information going on who knows
you know exactly what happened it's not
good enough to say it's a fact there's a
there's a name for uh effect i don't
remember the name of it but uh it
describes this phenomenon the name
doesn't really is it dunning-kruger
danny kruger is a good one that's in
this in this thing that he talks about
but there's an effect like this uh which
is like there's something that happens
where you read a newspaper story
and
let's say
day to day you read the newspaper you
say okay this is good it's informing me
i trust this this must be true if it's
here
and then you read about something you
know about and you actually see oh my
god like i actually know about this and
this is actually either not quite right
totally off or misses it leaves out some
important information
so you would think that people would
once they have that experience they
would like re-adjust
their trust in the rest of the newspaper
and the name of the effect is this some
kind of like amnesia effect where like
you um
you turn the page and then you resume
trusting the next thing that you didn't
know about that's in the newspaper it's
like even though you just sort of proved
to yourself
that like this should not be the you
know the record the canon of like what's
true and what's what's not about a
subject
um but there's this common effect which
is that people will experience it on
something they know and then as soon as
they get back to something they don't
know they uh sort of rebound back i
forgot the name of that but i've seen
this to be true you know for me for me i
i i hope at least at least you know that
was one of the biggest changes of my
childhood was i used to think if
something was in the newspaper or on cnn
that like
yes that's what it is and you know
and you know it changes it
when you become the person writing it so
i became the person writing it you know
i created a website and i would write
stuff and i saw people cite it sometimes
you and i will say stuff and we're
saying like around or we're saying i
heard this crazy story about x y and z
and hopefully we think that people are
saying like you know this is just banter
and like we don't it's when we do know
the facts we'll say it's a fact so but
oftentimes we're like you know i think
it's around blank and i'll see people
cite us and i'm like well you took that
out of context so i i was just i wasn't
well researched on that i was just kind
of i kind of knew it and once you become
the person making the news you see that
it's and that's why i believe
that fake news even though people are
like criticizing trump for that i'm like
that is actually real it's very easy to
make fake this you know
what's the difference between you know
cnn and the wwe there's not much they
make up story lines for entertainment
and uh and so like you know the
all these three-letter acronyms the nfl
same way it's story lines for
entertainment and like if you say that
the news
is just reality tv right it's story
lines loosely based on reality um that's
very different than you know getting
your information from it and i get it
it's tiring to go try to get accurate
first-hand information a lot and people
use shortcuts and that's why that's why
the system is the way it is
but um you know the sooner you
sooner you realize that the news is just
entertainment the faster you'll either
stop consuming it or consume it with
like a very severe filter that says this
may or may not be true i'd like to
cross-check this again if it's important
i should go dig into it if it's not
important
you know i should kind of like you know
take it with a grain of salt
this is great
[Music]
you